bonjour ici c'est snif kaufmann de l'unc
et aujourd'hui je vais faire une réponse
par vidéo
une question qui a été posée sur notre
forum à link à marina qui dit bonjour
j'ai plusieurs questions combien de
temps par semaine devrait être consacrée
minimalement aux langues et quel type
d'activité de 20 ans prioriser le temps
plus on dépense plus on passe de temps
avec avec la langue qu'on veut apprendre
plus vite on va prendre ça c'est certain
j'ai fait l'expérience dans beaucoup de
langues
si vous n'avez que 30 minutes par jour
passé de 30 minutes avec la langue
quand je dis passer du temps avec la
vente ça veut dire lire écrire parler
écouter ça ne veut pas dire lire des
livres de livres de grammaire parce
qu'il faut que le cerveau s'habitue et
rolande 30 minutes c'est pas beaucoup
quand je veux apprendre landes j'ai
plutôt la tendance de passer une heure
une heure et demie mais quand maintenant
parce que j'ai d'autres activités mais
il ya 25 ans quand j'apprenais le
chinois ben j'ai passé 6 7 heures par
jour mais j'avais de toute une variété
d'activités je lisais j'écrivais
j'apprenais les leaf tas de choses donc
autant de temps qu'on a c'est la réponse
minimalement je crois que le plus
important c'est de faire ça chaque jour
donc si vous avez 30 minutes par jour
donc dépenser des fonds tenue c'est ont
souvent on pense qu'on n'a pas le temps
mais il faut savoir par exemple dans mon
cas si je passe une heure
une heure et demie ou même des fois deux
heures par jour c'est parce que j'écoute
beaucoup et j'ai la possibilité
d'écouter dans la voiture j'écoute
pendant que je fais la vaisselle quand
je fais des exercices je me promets
n'importe quoi on a toujours la
possibilité d'utiliser des moments morts
pendant la journée pour se consacrer à
la langue donc il n'y a pas de minimum
sauf que il vaut mieux faire ça chaque
jour
deuxième question la rue blaes à cela
fait plusieurs fois que j'essaie
d'apprendre l'anglais dans là bas mais
je ne réussis pas et elle dit plus tard
je comprends très bien en anglais bon si
vous comprenez très bien donc c'est à
dire vous comprenez quand vous écoutez
vous comprenez quand vous lisez
alors à ce moment là il faut commencer à
parler beaucoup parce que si vous avez
déjà ses bases
vous avez déjà le vocabulaire vous
comprenez bon alors là il faut parler
mais il faut parler beaucoup et vous
allez faire des fautes
vous n'allez pas trouver les mots il y
aura beaucoup de problèmes mais plus
vous allez parler mieux ça sera
vous n'allez pas parler de plus en plus
mal donc la hippie pays quand quand vous
parlait il faut se rend compte que là
vous parlez pour communiquer donc ce
n'est pas une compétition
il faut pas se demander est-ce que j'ai
bien parlé
il faut pas trop s'en faire des
problèmes des fautes et erreurs qu'on a
commises il faut communiquer et il faut
essayer de prendre du goût du plaisir
dans cette communication
même avec toutes les difficultés et qui
petit épicier voir donc il faut parler
voilà ensuite a dit j'aimerais aussi
non parce que je veux dire je
m'intéresse aux prix germanophone
blablabla est bon à ce moment là comme
vous savez puisque vous êtes manque de
link je crois beaucoup à l'importance de
la lecture et l'écoutent
c'est à dire qu'il faut accumuler des
mots parce que si vous n'avez pas de mot
vous n'allez pas comprendre et si vous
ne comprenez pas vous n'allez pas
pouvoir communiquer donc je vous propose
de faire de créer beaucoup de lignes
donc de sauvegarder beaucoup de mots et
d'expressions sur ligue 2 lire et
surtout lire des choses qui vous
intéressent
même si ce sont des choses plus
difficiles un peu plus avancé ce n'est
pas grave parce que alik là vous pouvez
sauvegarder les mots les expressions
vous pouvez ensuite les relire et une
fois sauvegarder ses mots et ses
expressions sont soulignés en jaune et
chaque fois coup pour rencontrer ses
mots et ses expressions vous avez
sauvegardé déjà souligné un jour pour
vous rappeler que vous avez rencontré ce
mot avant et pour tout de suite voir la
signification de ce mot en rencontrons
simoes expression dans 2
des nouveaux contextes vous à les
accumuler des mots même sans trop de
voir faire défendre
c'est une chose que j'ai appris parce
que j'ai pas mal d'expérience maintenant
dans l'apprentissage des langues et je
me rappelle il ya peut-être dix ans
quand j'ai commencé à apprendre le
portugais et je parlais déjà l'espagnol
j'ai essayé de maîtriser chaque chapitre
dans ce petit bouquin j'avais acheté
j'avais acheté c'est pas possible
elle a on se crée des difficultés
maintenant que j'apprends le crânien et
le polonais je lis j'écoute
s'il ne comprend pas c'est pas grave je
lis je découvre de nouvelles modes de
nouveaux mots que j'ai que sauvegarde et
je sais que avec l'accumulation du temps
juste par le fait de m'exposer à la
langue de découvrir la langue le cerveau
va s'habituer et un moment donné je vais
commencer à parler
voilà c'est tout et elle dit aussi que
marine a dit qu'elle fait beaucoup de
fautes d'orthographe
bon en anglais c'est normal comme il est
c'est fait moi je ne me fais pas trop de
souci il faut des les mollahs coup là
vous faites des fautes d'orthographe
sauvegardez moalic essayer de les
réviser dans les travées l'arcade
mais maintenant il ya des trucs comme ça
moi je crois que l'important c'est de
comprendre des coupes de thèmes de
comprendre quand on écoute quand on
écoute dans son lit et de parler et si
vous écrivez avec des fautes
à moins que ce soit nécessaire pour
votre votre travail
ses moyens si c'est nécessaire pour
votre travail pour essayer de voir où
sont les mots ou vous faites des fautes
d'orthographe
il ya beaucoup de natifs qui font des
fautes d'orthographe
c'est pas facile c'est une question
d'entraînement est de continuer à faire
attention à ces mots là qui vous donne
est déposée difficulté est bien décrire
et quelqu'un vous corriger mais c'est
pas dans la correction que vous allez
vous améliorer c'est vous même sans être
corrigée qui doit devenir plus attentive
à ces questions d'orthographe voilà
c'est la réponse et si vous avez
d'autres questions ou même d'autres
personnes
même des questions en contrôlant que je
vais essayer de répondre par vidéo merci
et bonne chance dans et bon courage au
revoir